で もう 二十八種類の識の中で眼識という幻想があるんだと
ですから 眼識というものを働きを確定したのはなぜかというと
それは視覚の世界が我々の内なる心にあるんだから
我々は見たから いろんなものを作ったり
考えたり 悩んだりしているんだから
それは馬鹿にならない
見たんだから生まれる煩悩っていうのは数きれないんですね
見たんだから 我々には捨てることできない執着はいっぱいあるんじゃないですか
ですから 人間の輪廻転生する原因として見ると
これは馬鹿にならないんです
客観的に見ると 別にそんな大したことじゃないんですね
眼識っていうのは ただの目の中で生まれる直接の働きだけなんです
それは特別な項目に入れちゃって
特別な眼識という物質はあるんだよと確定するほどのものじゃないんだけど
認識の立場から 煩悩の立場から見ると馬鹿にならないもの
だから仏教はそういう角度で物質は区別するんです
物質物理学者の角度じゃないんです
煩悩についての問題なんですね
解脱の問題なんですね
いわゆる解脱論 煩悩論に基づいて物質論
物理学を喋っているんです
もっと現代風に言えば
認識論に基づいた物質論になっている
認識論ではなくて 認識過程に基づいた物質論になっているんです
だからアビダンマは現代科学にぴったし合う必要
合う必要は全くない これちょっと科学的には合わないんではないかと
だからちょっとまあよししましょうという言葉にはならない
私たちは科学者を追っかけていく必要は全くないんです
我々にとっては一番大事な問題はこういう問題である
科学者が考えている世界は全然問題にならない
例えばニュートリノあるんですよと
まあいろいろ素粒子あるんですが
勝手にあってもいいんですから
別にそれによって私に煩悩生まれたことはないんだから
考えの問題ないんです
じゃあ宇宙の中でどこかどこかで今新しい新星が発見しました
みんな驚いちゃうんですね
仏教はくだらないことをやるなと
ジャガイモでも植えればいいんじゃないかと
そんな暇があるならば
ということなんです なぜならば
だから新星発見して だからどうなるんですか？それだから私たちは新しい苦しみが生まれますか？あるいは新しい幸福が生まれますか？あるいは新しい煩悩が生まれます
か？あるいは持ってる煩悩は消えるんですか？何もないんです
あれはただの暇つぶしなんですね
はっきり言って ですから
そういう科学に合うように合うようにと仏教は努力しない
でも一つは仏教はすごく傲慢というか
もう我が強いところがあるんですね
じゃあ仏教の世界にチャレンジしてみようと
あんたがたはいろんな科学的な進歩して発展発展してきて
じゃあ当たってみろと
どうなるんですかと それがこちらの方が強いって話なんですね
今私が喋ってるのは これ二千五百年の古い
何の科学もなかった時代でお坊さんたちが開発した心理学なんですね
それをお釈迦様はそこまでやってないんです
なさってないんです お釈迦様さえ
これも面倒くさいな 余計な話だと
お釈迦様はただの仏教だけ喋ってたんですね
それは後のお坊さんたちが
やっぱりアビダンマ論というものは組織化しましたから
物質じゃないんです ですから
物質でもないアビダンマ論にしたっても
科学の世界にはもう何のことなくチャレンジできる
チャレンジする必要は全くバカバカらしいことですけどね
いわゆる比べ 肩は並べるというか
もっとちょっと違う立場にいるか
科学者さえ助けてあげることができる立場にいるんですね
科学者でもやっぱり夫婦喧嘩するは
離婚するは がんになったところで悩んだりするは
お金がなくて研究できなくて困ったりするわね
まあそういう精神的なもんでいっぱいあるんだから
それを誰が助けてあげるんですかと
やっぱりこういう世界でしか助けてあげることできませんから
心を平らにするとか そういうことでも我々の立場が違うとということを理解しておいてください
そこでチャックという働きがあります
チャックというのは目ですね
目で光が映るんだと 目に光が映るんだというのは物理学者なんです
目で認識できるのは光だよと
この光を映したところで
目の後ろの膜の中で細胞の色があります
その色は変化するんだ
その色が変化したら それは神経で電気信号を通して感じるんだと
そこで化学的な変化を起こして
ずっと脳までその化学変化は繋がるんだと
それで脳細胞の中で映像を作り出すんだというのは
医学の世界で 物理学的な世界の解釈なんですね
説明なんですね それは
別に証拠があるんじゃなくて
いろいろ情報を見て そういうふうに説明する
それが説明だから推測なんです
仏教から見れば 直感で見ると
私は目を閉じる 目を開ける
開けた瞬間に私の頭が
心がこの部屋を認識する
何を認識するかというと
形と色を認識する 色を認識してるんですね
結局は 色なければ見えない
見えます？空気見えますか？あるんだけど
なぜ見えないんですか？色がないんだから
空気に色を付けてみてください
きちんと見えるんです
光で見えるんだったら
これずっと光があるのに
空気の中通ってるんだから
見えないんです 空気に色をつけたって別に大したことないんだけど
同じく空気として光は流れますよ
それでも空気を色付けちゃったら見えるんですから
だから認識から見れば
見えてるのは色であることは明確なんですね
というガラスの板だったら
これガラスの板だと見えますけど
それにそれだったら色はあるはずなんです
それなければ見えないんです
ガラスとはなんで水の中に入れちゃったら見えないんですか？色は同じくなってしまっちゃいますから
どっちがどっちかと分からなくなっちゃうんですね
ちゃんとあるんだから見えるはずなのに
どっちかと分からなくなっちゃうんです
なんでガラスの板の裏に絵とかなんとかつけて壁なんかに貼っちゃったら
ガラスではなくて下の絵に見えるんですかと
逆に下の絵の色が派手だからガラスの色が負けてしまっちゃうんです
だから見える 我々はこの目のごまかしはちゃんと直感で知ってるんです
知恵では知らない ですから
みんな色の世界 デザインの世界
映画の世界 いろんなものを作ってるでしょう
それはちゃんとみんなこの何が人間認識して
何を妄想するかと その過程をよく知ってるんです
例えば映画なんか作る人々は
このSF映画やいろんなものは
そこら辺をきめ細かく勉強してるんですね
人間の幻覚の世界 妄想の世界
人間が何を見て何を考えるんだと
例えば人が人の映像をする
そこでもう一人の人はすごい鋭い剣
刀ですか 持っている こうやっているのを見せる
それで次に人の首だけ見せる
そこで我々頭の中で あれでこの人の首を切ったと妄想する
それ知ってるんだからつなげて
何も訳もないんだけど
頭の中でササササとこのもう理屈つけちゃうんですね
人間それ理屈だと思っても簡単に屁理屈でしょうね
映画では別に人は殺しませんだから撮影のために
SF という映画っていうのは
人間が何が常識だと決まってるんですね
これは常識だと そこでそうでないものを創れば
なんで SF なんですね
すごい単純なんです 例えば人の体には完全に肉つけてるのは常識ですね
それで SF の場合は 人の半分はきちんとした人間で
肉がついて皮膚があって
この半分は骨にすると
そうするとみんな SF 映画だ
それだけのこと ですから
仏教からでも そういうこの人間の心の働きの
このバカバカらしさを発見すれば
もう何でもできるんですよ
何でも もういとも簡単にできるんです
文章書けないと思ってる人がいるでしょ
才能がないんだとかね
人間がどんな妄想するかと
どれぐらいアホかと分かってしまえば
抜群の強力なインパクトある文章を書けるんです
こういう本作ったり いろんなことをやったりすると
みんなもう 3ヶ月間かけて苦労してこの構成作ったりします
僕は大体 5分しか使わないんですね 5
分でこれとこれとこれこれこれじゃ
これで悪いと言っちゃいますね
それなぜかというと 人間はこのどう考えるかってもうもう分かってしまえば
もうすごい簡単なんです
何かテーマ決めちゃったら
僕でも 5 分  1分  2分もかかりません
テーマに据えて 全部この項目ごとにきめ細かく分けて
どういう風に喋った方がいいんですか？何を喋った方がいいんですかと決めると
喋るという働きには時間がかかりますけどね
なぜかというと そういうテーマにして
人間とはすぐこんな風に考えちゃいますよ
もう決まってる そんなものはもうどうしようもないんです
例えば超能力と仏教と言った途端
皆様は何を考えるかと
僕はサッとその瞬間に知っています
だからそれを認めてあげよう
攻撃してあげようという
僕の気持ち次第でもう何を喋るか決めちゃうんです
病気と心で言った途端
人間が何考えるかと もう決まってるんです
病気と心の関係 あるいは体と心の関係という
いろんな仏教的なテーマあるんじゃないですか
テーマ決めたら内容は皆様もうすでに頭の中でもあるんですね
だからそれはそのままおだててあげようか
直してあげようか 壊してあげようかということによって
僕の講義内容が変わるだけのことなんです
その世界 映画の世界でも
SF の世界でも どこでもあるんですね
それは自分の分野に捕まった人はプロになるんですね
音楽の世界で人間はどこでバカになりましたと知っている人だけが音楽のプロになるし
映画の世界で人間何を見て何を考えるかとかった人は立派な映画
立派というか それは別の話でね
まあたとえくだらない
もう貧弱な映画を作るにしたっても
その頭の働きを勉強しなきゃできないんです
いろんな映画でこの爆弾かけたりとかあるでしょ
そこで爆弾ある人がいて
これはもう解除したりするし
そこでどんな映画見てください
最後の 1 秒 2 秒でやっともう解除しましたと
そこまで大変ですね なぜか
それ決まってるんです
人間が爆弾見たらビクビクするだろうと
そこでチクチクと時計をもう逆に行くと
もうさらにさらにもう鳴ったりしたりとか
そこで赤線切るか緑の線切るかというギリギリのところに持ってきて
そこで本人もどっちかわからないところ
もうカチカバチか考えなくても
とにかく何かを切るとか
その世界で見る人もこうなっていて
ああやった よかったという風に落ち着いて
そんなもう心の働きってのはもう決まってるんです
だからどんな映画でも
そういう爆弾狙ってろたら
そういう活動あるならば
決まってるパターンで動いています
進化しますからね だからお金払って見るのはもう本当にもったいないということで
そんなものは仏教では見るなと言ってるんだよね
僕にとっては人をバカにしていることと
それに人をバカにされること自体が面白いこと見るんです
感動はしません 全然 どんな恐ろしい恐怖があふれている映画を見ても
かすかにでも怖くはならないし
すっごいこのビクビクするようなものを見ても全然全くないんだけども
眠くなっちゃうんですね
本当は でも一生懸命馬鹿にしてあげようと頑張ってるところを見ると
僕はかえって笑っちゃうんです
大体見る人でもそんな気持ちもありますから
まあそろそろこうなるでしょうとね
分かりますかね  そういうことで
目で見えるのは結局は光
光ではなくて色 次に音
耳 耳という働きがあります
それは我々知っているのは耳なんですね
二ついてますから こんななんで二ついてるんですかね
これ我々三次元の世界でいるんだからなんです
この三次元ですか この高さと幅と深さですか
それはチャネル二つで情報が入ったらもう出来上がっちゃうんです
もし人間に目が四つ 四つ
耳が四つ 四つあったならば違う世界なんです
対策上には千ぐらいあるんだそうですね
目は だから四次元の世界にいるでしょうね
[笑い]で 耳っていうのは
我々はこの外の世界の存在を知る一つの方法なんですね
耳に入るのはただの音というある一種の働き
それは感知できる 認知できる
ですから 耳という意識があるんだというんです
そこで耳というのはどういうものかというと
このチースウィカーフォーの中
あの組み合わせの中で音に反応するようになってしまっちゃうだけ
音に反応する場合は そこには
二式あるんだと というんです
まあ大体そんなことで理解できるでしょうね
音を感じるところには二式という
それで我々の認識の世界
香りにも左右されるんですね
まあほとんどの人間の世界っていうのは
目と耳でまあ結構大きな世界使ってますけど
そこで香りも捨てたもんじゃないんですね
香りによって我々は怒ったり楽しがったり
執着を作ったり 欲を作ったりとかね
貪欲やら瞋恚やらいろんなものを作ったりするんですね
香りに対して そこできつい悪臭なんか目に
鼻に入っちゃったら人間が意識がもうなくなっちゃうんですね
すごい強烈なんですね
僕にしても この目から何見たっても平気で実質見られますけど
耳からどんな音入ったって全く冷静に見ることできるんだけど
やっぱり鼻の訓練してない場合あるんですね
香りには別に全く平気でいられますけど
たまにいきなり悪臭なんか入っちゃったら
もう体いきなり変化を起こしちゃうんですね
起こしても気持ち悪くなったりとか
体の調子がすごく悪くなったりとか
ちょっと鼻の穴から香り入っただけで発作が出たりとかはあるんです
で ただの香りなんです
香りというんですけど
こうですかもう 香りって言ったらなんかいいものになっちゃいますけどね
そんなもんなんです ですから
代わりに香りという働きは私たちにとっては大変な重大な問題で無視することはできない
それによって我々の心は汚れたり
綺麗になったり 幸福になったり
不幸になったり いろいろするんです
それによって我々は輪廻転生しているんです
囚われて それ大してそれによって存在があるんだと
私は死ぬんだと 死ぬのはちょっと惜しいんだと
やっぱり死にたくないんだといろんなことを生まれる
それによって輪廻転生するんです
死んでもまた同じ働きが生まれてきちゃうし
ですから その色も大変人間生命としては大事な重大な色であります
でも色自体としては何のことないんです
ただ 鼻の中でちょっとした敏感さがありますよ
それで香りを感じてしまった
敏感な体どこでも敏感なんですね
例えば 鼻の中よりは口の中の方がすごく柔らかくて敏感なんです
でも口では香りは全然わからない
例えばこの口の中の粘膜と言うんですか
粘膜 そういうところなんかもうちょっと触れただけでも
すごくあの痛いと感じるするし
私の場合はちょっと熱いものでも口に入っちゃったら
すぐ皮膚が全部抜けちゃうんですね
そのまま抜けちゃうんです
火傷するですからね でも香りはいくら口に入ったって
それは全然わからない
鼻の中なんか指出す もうこうやって指を入れて
もうぐるぐる回ることでも平気でできるんですね
すごく硬くて そういう鼻にちょっときつい香りなんか入っちゃったら
頭が痛くて涙が出きもう倒れちゃうんです
その敏感さなんですね
鼻の中では香りに敏感です
ですから そこは大事に
別な色として 別な現象として確定しましょうというのが仏教の話なんですね
次に出てくるのは何でしたっけ
舌 ジッハ ジッハというのは舌
舌で何を感じるかというと味ですね
もうここの辺でちょっと余計な話なんですけど
この日本でいう日本語でいう美味しいという言葉はすごい曖昧ですね
日本で美味しいっていうのは
見て美味しい 暖かくて美味しいと
冷たくて美味しいと 歯触りが良くて美味しいと
柔らかくて美味しいと
美味しいって何ですか？と
その美味しいっていうのは一つの大きな妄想概念で
もうその食べるものを持っている形
色 それから熱量 それから硬さとか
いろんなものをまとめて
それからあの 何て言いますか
世の中あれ それにはこの量
何て言いますか すごいいいものという
あの認めているかどうか
そういう概念もあって
美味しいと言うんですね
実際に食べにくいものでも
すごい高価なもので 珍しいものであったら
もうすごい美味しいと言っちゃいますから
そういうことだから この美味しいという我々俗的に言っている言葉は
あの まあちょっと曖昧で
仏教ではちょっと使いにくいんですね
仏教でいう舌で感じる味っていうのは
舌だけで感じるものなんです
例えばラーメンを食べると美味しいという場合は
ラーメンはすごくもう冷たくなってるならば
誰も美味しいって言わないんですね
暖かくなければいけませんということもありますから
その場合はこの体で感じる熱も計算するんですね
美味しいというためには
仏教アビダンマで言うのは
そういうこの口で感じる熱ではなくて
舌で感じる味だけ 味覚だけ
だから舌で感じる味覚だけこの感じて
その味覚を感じる力は舌にしかないんです
もし試しにハチミツでもこの唇やら唇の中やら塗ってみてください
舌の裏にハチミツ塗ってみてください
感じるかな 全然感じないんです
すごい苦いものでもいいし
この舌の裏とか塗ってみてください
全然わからないんです
それは舌の上に あの 何て言いますか
唾液と一緒に溶けてくるともうびっくりするんですけど
その局部ですか その味覚が生まれる局部は舌というわけです
この色には赤やら青やら色々あるような感じで
人間に見えるのは色ですけどね
大体赤やらいろいろありますね
そういう風にこの味もいくらかの種類があるんですね
これ何種類あるんですかね
まあ大体まあ味も七種類ぐらいあるんじゃないかなという場合もありますけどね
色も基本的に色は三四色しかないんだけど
やっぱり人間にとっては色はもう千ぐらいでも
まあ 三万 コンピューターの数字だけ見れば
まあ 千七 一万七千色とかあるんだけど
あるかはわかりませんだけど
まあそれはただの組み合わせで
基本的に見れば四色しかないし
味の場合もいろんな味があるんだけど
基本的にはね 苦みやら甘みと酸っぱさ
しょっぱさと 日本語で使っている言葉で旨味という味もありますけど
ヒンディーの世界 インドの文化では七つですね
味は 七種類あるんです
その七種類も付いてる果物一つあるんです
七種類の味は別々に付いてる
あれ？果物っていうのはあれ薬なんですけどね
すっごいカルシウムとかCビタミンが入ってるんです
このCビタミンっていうのは熱には分解するんですね
あれはもう煮ても焼いても分解しないんです
ですからアーユルヴェーダではすぐ効き目が必要ですから
この果物の薬に使う 干しても使ったりするし
煮て飲むし で 親たちは我々いろんなこの野生の藪に生えていろんな果物取ったり食べてるんだから
まあいろいろあれ食べなさいとか
なんとか間接的に何か引っ張り合わせるものを食べた方が体にいいんですから
まあ鈴木さんにも廣田さんにもあげたんだけど
嫌われたんだけど で この七つの味があるんだから
あるんだから美味しいということじゃないんです
別々ですから こうすごくこの美味しくないんです
だから例えばしょっぱさと酸っぱさが別々に入っちゃうんですね
同時に別にもう甘さも入っちゃう
それで口で噛むと 口の中でいくらか
僕らの僕らも食べられないんですね
もうなんかもう梅干しは決まってる味だから食べられるんですよ
だからもうこう もうもうね
口をもう麻酔しながらも梅干しは食べられます
味が決まってるんだから
あれはもうどんな顔して食べたか分からないぐらいもう
で 口の中で僕らのやり方っていうのはサササササッと噛んじゃうんですね
噛むと噛むともう全部味がまとめてまとめてまとめて
まあなんとなく甘く感じるようになるんです
あれ すごい変な果物なんです
果物というのはほんの小さいんです
すごい小さい この二人ともあげたことはあげたんです
とにかく まあ別に僕は何の意味じゃなくて
ただ自分に面白いんだから
どんな顔するかな この果物で思い出さないのは
これ このバナナとかリンゴとか
このそういうマンゴーとか
そんな形ではなくて もうちょっとしたこのもう口で噛んでみるものぐらいの小さいものですから
まあそれは別に関係ないんだけど
とにかくインドの世界では 7つの味があるんだと
であのと言っていて まあそこは別に
まあそのまあどうでもいいんですけど
いろいろ味だけはあるんですね
いくらか 大体人間わかっているのは塩味と酸っぱさと甘みと苦みとぐらいのことでしょうね
明確にわかるのは で また五眼部 5番目に体が入ってしまっちゃうんです
5番目の色は体ですよ
なんかえらいこのダブってるんですかというか
矛盾というか 体自体は一つの色
一つの物質ですかと聞きたくなるでしょ
こちらで体というのは
我々は体でいろんな情報
いろんな情報じゃなくて
認識するんですね ものを
その体の働きに心色というんです
いわゆる触れる感覚なんですね
体という肉体の塊 ここで考えてないんです
体というこの巨大な肉体の塊の中で何かに触れたら
それはわかるんですね
そこをその働きに心色というんです
それで量的に言えば 舌
体の方が大きい 舌の方がより小さい
鼻の方がもっと小さい
耳の方がもっと小さい
目の方がもっと小さい量なんですね
物質の量見れば でも私たちのことは目から見れる情報の量がすごい大きいと思ってるし
耳からいろんなことを知ってるんではないかと思ったりするし
鼻からはそんな大したことないと思ってますけど
まあ口からはまあ食べ物の問題もありますからね
味には結構断ったりはするんだけど
でもあまり断らない人も結構いるし
体からはそんなに大変なそんな大変なことを感じないではないかと思いますけど
やっぱり体から入る情報
どう言えばいいんでしょうかね
器が大きいんですね とにかく体という
それにいろんなものが触れちゃう
触れるものはわかる いわゆるこの皮膚を持っている
この敏感性ですか 感受性に心色というんですね
そこで皮膚だけじゃなくて
いろんなところにあるんです
例えば舌に蜂蜜を入れたら甘いと感じますけど
舌に指を入れたら指の感触はわかるんですね
その場合は 舌の上にある心色が指の感触を感じているんです
指に蜂蜜も塗っておけば
舌の心色が指の重さ感じて
舌にある節色が蜂蜜の甘さを感じる
仕事はきちんと分けてるんです
で 例えば鼻に香りが通ると香りが分かりますね
それは空気と空気と一緒にいかないとわかりません
それで鼻に水を入れちゃったら何が感じますか？その場合もちゃんと感じるんです
でも香りが感じるわけじゃなくて
この体で感じるんですね
鼻という体です まあそういうことは一応まあ簡単なことだからね
鼻に入るものは全部香りだよっていうことじゃないんです
鼻に水入れちゃったら香りじゃなくて
この痛いとかね きついとかね
というふうに痛みを感じる
ですから 目から涙も飛んじゃう
その時は鼻の中にあるこの自色は働かない
舌に口にお湯入れたら
舌が働くんじゃなくて
口の中の神識が働いて熱いと感じちゃうんです
その時は舌には仕事がない
舌色には仕事はない 神識にはいっぱい仕事がある
とにかくこの体にいろんなものを触れると
我々はそれを知っています
体に触れるのは硬さと温度だけと前に説明しましたし
そういう 5つの働き とにかくチャックっていうのは
また違う言葉で定義するならば
チャックっていうのは目の感受性
そう 耳っていうのは耳の音を受ける音を受信する感受性
これは音の受信機能なんですね
音っていう字 で 鼻 鼻っていうのは香りを受信する感受性
受信できる感受性 舌っていうのは味を
味覚を受信できる感受性
で カヤっていうのはいろいろ外の情報体を受信する感受性
それで何を受信するかというと
やっぱり地水火風しかないんだから
世の中に物質は 結局地水火風のもういろいろぐるぐる回ることだけなんですね
目で何が見えるかというと
地水火風しか見えませんし
耳で何が聞いてるんですか？地水火風しか聞いてないし
じゃあ舌で何を感じていますか？というと
もうそれは味覚で言ったって地水火風なんですね
体で感じているのは結局は地水火風なんですけど
このチャネルによって知識が違っちゃうんですね
舌のチャネル通っちゃったら味覚という
耳のチャネル通っちゃったら
耳覚 耳通ったらまあ味覚
何覚だね 聴覚と読むんです
聴覚という そういう風に我々は言葉で区別するんですね
結局はもう地水火風しかありません
あるんではないんだけど
認識の中でいろいろ様々な変化を起こしてくれるんだから
変化を起こすものには違うラベルを貼ってあげる
じゃあそれは基本的なこのパサーベルパサーベル
っていうのは このパサードのやっぱりこの感受性意味してるんですね
あの こちらの注釈の解釈
ちょっと違うかもしれませんだけど
結局無茶苦茶なこと言ってます
結局感受性なんですね sensitivity
英語で言えば感受性 まあそのようにまあ小さい科学だけ言うと
まあ宇宙もまとめて全ての物質素になってしまっちゃいますけど
それからの分はただのまあまあ人間の生命の説明に入ってしまっちゃう
じゃあ次の まあそれもそれで一応終わりまして
何か疑問やらまだわからないというところがありますかね
あまりにも説明しすぎてわからない可能性はあるんです
説明はすごいしすぎなんです
僕は勉強した時はまあチャックソータガはカーエパーサドルーパンそれで終わった
それ以上説明しないんです
で ゴーチェルーパンもうゴーチェルーパン7つですからね
ループサッドガンダラスポッターポッターにはまあパタジーテージョワーヨ
それで終わった まあただこうこうこういうこと的なことだから
だから説明すると思うとそこまでって
まあいろいろ余計なんですけど
まあとにかくまあそういう物質の中
物質の中で同じ物質の中で少々働きが変わるということのだけで
それで一つの働きだけ特別に言ってて
他の働きはあってもなくても関係ないこと
認識は生まれませんだから
で 次にこのゴーチェレルーパというところやります
こちらは7つで こちらが1つ
一応あのゴーチェレルーパっていうのは7つあると書いてます
一応勉強する場合は ルーパサッドガンダラサポッターバという風に覚えちゃうんです
まあこのテキスト通りに言えば
まあルーポサッドガンダラサポッターバとなります
ポッターバの場合 そういう
ゴーチルルーパの日本語の名前何でしたっけ？教師
それがエコーか 今日っていう名前とか
ではこれから説明いたします
で これももう一つのこの絵式で地杉家譜があるんだだから一応こういうものもあるという風にいるだけで
別に独立してあるものじゃない
1番目は色というんですね
そこで我々現代的な言葉の世界で考えると
ちょっとややこしくなるんですね
今はずっと色の分析してるんだから
その中にまた式が入っちゃいますからね
そこら辺ちょっと言葉の使い方はね
ちょっと混乱するんです
パーリ語の人でも違う言葉使った方がいいかもしれませんだけど
そんなに単語はないかった可能性もありますね
それから あるいは一般的な人々に
専門家ではなくて 全くごく普通な人々の理解をよく考えていたんだから
そういう混乱するように
単語にはそんなに神経使ってないっていうことがある可能性もあります
色という場合は この物質にも色という言葉を使ってまして
この漢字の通りに色という意味もあります
それ今は色っていう意味で取っちゃうんです
この場合は色 普通に色と名色やら 28色やら
そういう場合は色ではなくて物質の世界という風になっちゃうんですね
ここで色というと そんなことじゃなくて色
カラー  うん でもいいし
そこでルーパというところで
パーリ語からもう一つ形という意味があるんです
例えば あの 女性を見て驚いたとパーリ語で言うならば
女性のイッティというんですね
イッティという言葉を言ってもいいし
イッティナルーパンディスワと言ったっても構いません
それはイッティナ女性のルーパン
これを形を見てとか 例えばハッティといえば像
ハッティルーパンといえば像の形
像そのものでも構いません
像の形を作った何が作り物でも構いません
ですから形という意味もありますね
それで絵 絵にもルーパというんです
それからこれ掘ったものとかね
彫刻とかそういうものにもルーパというんです
まあそういう風に まあもういろんなものに使ってしまっちゃう
そこら辺は勉強を始めて勉強する人々にとってはもうかなり困る
特に外国はパーリのその文化でない人が勉強するとは結構困ったりする可能性はあるんですね
いろいろこの思想的に変化になったりという意味とそれなんです
この部派仏教と大乗仏教の世界でも
特に中国に入って日本になってきたら仏教でなくなっちゃって
またいろんな違う違う考え方が生まれたのは
この言葉の解釈なんですね
いろんな意味で取れちゃいますから
それで自分知ってる意味で取っちゃって
それで解釈してしまっちゃうんです
そこをまあまあ言えば
それはすごくパーリサンスクリットのまあちょっとした問題なんですね
まあそれでルーパというものにはいろいろ意味がありまして
ここではだいたい色 形というふうな即的な意味で使う
そこでなんでルーパという物質がありますかというと
ここでチャック 目で私たちは何かを認識する
その目で認識する何かにここでルーパと呼ぶんです
そこで目で何かを認識するということは
なんで大事ですかというと
例えば私はじーっと落ち着いて
すごくもう落ち着いてはいるんだけど
なんかつまらなくなっていると
そこで目を閉じているんだと
目を開けた途端 びっくりは思ってもいない誰か人が立ってるんだと
目を開けた途端 そこに蛇がいたんだと
そこで僕は驚いてびっくりして飛び上がっちゃうという反応はするんだと
今まではつまらなくて
ぼけーっとしてやることもないわ
つまらないわという暗い心でいたのに
目を閉じて目を開けた途端蛇が入っちゃったでしょ
で 僕はびっくりしちゃって
飛び上がっちゃって あのつまらないとかあんなことではなくて
もう慌てて焦って怖くて怯えていろいろ反応が起こるかもしれません
でもそれぐらい変化が実際に起きたんだから
体の中心の変化も体の変化もその変化で何か目から入ったんだから起きたんですね
それは否定できませんね
ですから 目を開けると我々の心は変化する
心が変化すると同時に体も変化してしまう
例えば綺麗な美人が並んでいるところで
自分たちがずっと見て歩くんだ
それで真ん中に歳のおばあちゃんがいたんだから
すぐそれを見ただけで心の持ち方がすぐ変化しちゃいますから
例えば水着なんか見せている
いろいろありますね こういう何て言います
デモンストレーションみたいなの
そこでみんな二十歳以下の女の子たちが並んでいるところで
もしね 歳くらいのおばあちゃんも水着姿でいたと
で 見て見て歩いたら やっぱりすぐ変化が起こるでしょうに
ですから 目から情報が入ることによって
心で心と体に変化が起こる
それは馬鹿にならない
それは無視することはできないのです
そういう変化が我々の問題だから
怒りも嫉妬も煩悩もなんだかんだ言っても
苦しみも幸福もそういう変化ですから
ですから 目で受けられる
目で受けられるというか
受信できる物質に色というんです
それは厳密に何ですかと聞いたら地水火風なんですね
それは別にここでは気にしない
じゃあ 2番目 声と声と書いてるんですね
まあ仏教の発音が声ですね
これは普通の ですけどね
声ってもう言わとなりましょう
声ですね そこで声っていうのは耳で受信できるんですね
だから耳耳で受信できるエネルギーに声という
エネルギーは地水火風でまとめなきゃエネルギーではないんです
そこで鼻で受信できるエネルギーに香と香りというんですね
舌で受信できるエネルギーに味と味というんです
そこで体で受信できるエネルギーに触と触れるという漢字を書いて触と読むんですね
触とも読む 発音するんですね
どっちでもいいんです
触でね 触 触と読むんですね
だからこの受信できることを大事であって
それからその受信によってこの体の中でいろんな変化が起こることは我々の人間の問題ですから
ですから そこら辺で特別な物質として確定しておきましょうと
ということ それに別に喧嘩する必要ないんですが
やっぱりそんなものないんではないかとか
実際は地水火風だけではないかとかね
討論する 喧嘩する必要はないんです
実際の存在として 人間としてはやっぱりあってもなくてもどうでもいいんだけど
心の中で変化することだけは確かですからね
何か見たら変化が起こる
何か聞いたら変化が起こる
何か味わったら変化する
起こる その変化によって
我々は煩悩でも怒りでも何でもいいから
いろんな問題は作る ですから 5つあるんですね
色声香味触 色声香味触
そこでここだけで体に触れるものは3種類あるんだと
地と風と このアビダンマッタサンガというテキストに書いてあるんですよ
私はよく言うのは地と火だけですけどね
これ違う伝統になると地と火だけなんです
アビダンマッタサンガの伝統では
地火風水  3つ感じるんだということになってますから
まあそういうのはまあ説明していることなんですけど
まあとにかくテキストにありますから
こういう風に使います
もし私の言い方で言っちゃったら
まあ私は困るんです 後でいろんなことを勉強して研究して言わなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんです
テキストがないので で
そこで体で触れるのは地と火と風という 3つ
それ体で感じる場合は触という言葉で使う
ですから計算してみると
目で感じるのは 地水火風というやつではなくて違うものなんです
それは後で説明します
それは一つしかない 音を通して感じるエネルギーも一つしかない
香りとして として感じるのも種類しかない
味として感じるのも種類しかない
でも触れることで感じる触として感じるエネルギーは種類があるんです
ですからゴーチャラルーパが座るんだ
言ってるんです ちょっとここら辺でわからなくなっても
これからの説明で大体これからといったっても
ちょっと先なんですけど
で そういうのはまた説明いたします
そこでこちらにゴーチャラルーパという
この境というのはどういう意味でしょう
境ということですから
これで我々は境作っちゃうんですね
自と他の境じゃない そうかもしれません
ゴーチャラというのは境という意味というよりも
一つのこの受け入れられるという意味なんだ
厳密に もうなんで境という言葉が使ってますかって
まあこれパーリ語もややこしいんだから
ゴーチャラという言葉にはいろいろまた変えという意味がありまして
ゴーというのは牛 チャラっていうのは歩くという意味なんです
牛が歩くということなんですね
だから牛が歩くってどういうことかというと
牛が餌を求めて歩くでしょ
縄張りなんですね 動物の縄張りっていうのは自分の餌をもらうと気持ちでしょ
だからゴーチャラというのは縄張りなんですね
そこで縄張りがあって何があります
その縄張りがあって生きてるんですね
普通だったら餌を取る気持ちだけですけど
そこから情報を取って生きてるんですね
その縄張りの中の音を聞いて
縄張りの中のものを食べて
その縄張りの中で寝て繁殖して生きてるんだから
だからそういういろんな普通の遠いアーリア人がの初めの文化の初めの時代の言葉で
今までの哲学的な発展したことものまで使ってしまっちゃうんです
もともとゴーチャラ ゴーは牛で
チャラっていうのは牛が歩き回っている辺という意味なんですね
そこでお坊さんたちが仏教では托鉢しに行く
例えばどこかに修行に入ったら
ここら辺でこの村で托鉢しに行きますよと自分でも簡単に決めちゃうんですね
これを修行者が決めるんではなくて
お坊さんが自分で好き勝手に
あの村の方に托鉢しに行きますよと
そこでその村に行って
何かご飯をもらって また帰って修行する
その場合はその村にゴーチャラガマと読むんですね
パーリ語で 牛が歩く村という意味しかないんです
例えばお坊さんが自分の食べ物をもらう村という意味なんですね
そこでゴーチャラっていうのは
もうそういう牛が歩くところだから
牛そこで何をもらうかというと餌なんですね
餌っていうのは動物の餌ですけど
人間にとって食べ物なんですね
ですから 食べ物にもその言葉を使っちゃうんです
特に動物の餌にはゴーチャラという言葉を使っちゃうんですね
これ 自分の国の言葉でも似てるんです
ゴドゥラという言葉を使って
これからディラビディリフィケーションした言葉ですけど
ゴドゥラと読むんですね
ゴドゥラというのは え
あの 獲物 餌 ですから 人間の言葉にそれを使わない
たまに あの すごく この
何て言いますか ある感じで
人間の食べ物を言う場合はそれ言うんですね
例えばやっと仕事をして
やっと自分が食べてる道ですよという場合は
この言葉使ってしまっちゃうんです
だからまあそういうふうなもので
まあそこに勉強すると
すごく世界が大きくて面白いんですね
言葉の発展っていうのは
単純な言葉をえらい哲学のところまで使ってしまっちゃいますからね
ラテン語も同じことをやっていますけど
ゴーチャラというのはそういう意味で
とにかく牛が歩く場所で
それから餌にあって それから生きているための自分の縄張り
それでなければ生きていられないんですね
そこで認識世界の縄張りは何ですかというと
ここなんです このつで
色声香味触というつは認識の縄張りなんですね
それは乗り越えられませんと
でも心の分析に入るともうちょっと変わりますけど
ここにもう一つ入りますけどね
今は入ってない 今は純粋な色の説明ですからね
今はちょっと抜いてるんです
認識の縄張りはもうちょっと一つあります
もう 1個 それはここで使ってない
そういうことで まあゴーチャラと言うんです
ですから 縄張りという意味で
まあ境という まあ感じは別に悪くはないんです
まあいい加減いろんな意味で使ってるんだからね
でも当時昔翻訳した人々はね
どれほど苦労しただろうかと思いますよ
遠い昔からね まあサンスクリット語から漢訳した時は
もう大変な苦労ですよ
こんなゴーチャラということは
いろんな辞書があるんですね
サンスクリット語にもパーリ語にも
昔から その辞書っていうのはすごい変な辞書で意味はない
意味はない辞書わからないでしょ
どんな辞書かと で それを暗記しなくちゃいけないんです
その言葉を勉強するためには
それは辞書と言わない
同義語の集 同義語集なんですね
この同義語集を暗記して
そこで言葉はどういうふうに使うかと
例えばこの同義語集でゴーチャラという言葉があります
それを引用したら その中に例文が入ってるんです
その例文でいろんな単語がたくさん入ってるんです
それを暗記するんです
それを単語を単語一つ一つ違う意味を持ってるんです
ですから ゴーチャラということは
こういうこういう意味で使えるぞということで理解できる
そして その中にもう一つ単語をまた引用して
その例文を見るとまた違う意味になる
だからそこで言葉の組み合わせ
積み重ね どうやって出てくるかということは頭に入っちゃうんです
それは勉強するとすっごく難しいんだから
一番早いのはあの同義語集を暗記することなんです
例えばゴーチャラということを暗記したところで
例えば二十四の言葉が出たんだと
そこで四番目の言葉を思い出しちゃったら
そちらの例文が出てくるんですね
それで ものすごく素晴らしく言葉を使えるような情勢になってしまっちゃうんです
間違いなく そこで漢文に訳したお坊さんたちも
もしかするとその同義語集使わなきゃ無理でしょう
これまた難しいけど 同義語集は分野ごとに別々なんです
医学の同義語集と 仏教的なそういう哲学の同義語集とか
また別々にありまして
あまりにも暗記できないほど恐ろしい量だから
みんな自分の分野のことしか勉強しない
こういうバラモン人が四十五歳になるまで勉強して
学生時代学生で勉強するんだそうですから
それから結婚しなさいと
それはまあ結局理想的な生き方なんですね
四十まで勉強して やっと学生終わって
それから結婚する そこまでありますよ
勉強するもんで まあそれからまあちょっとした気休めの話で
それはそれで終わって
あの まあいくらかそこら辺でゴーチャラルーパ
あるいはこの あの これSUBJECTですね
これはSUBJECTというこの体の世界
これはOBJECT世界
それは自の世界 これは他の世界ですね
それは主観的な世界で
こちらは客観的な世界
そういうものもいろんな普通の言葉でも理解できるんです
いわゆる眼耳鼻舌身は
主観の世界で自分の自分であって
色声香味触は客体の世界
自の他の世界と言ったってね
そういう風というとすごい大雑把ではっきりしない誤解招きやすい
主体の世界 客体の世界
自と他はなんですかとか
ああだこうだとなってるでしょ
ですから仏教でそんな哲学全然もう気にしないのはもう別にまあこんな働きだからということで
自も他にも争いとかいろんなこと言ってるでしょうね
まあそんなこと言ってもいいんですけどね
例えば自我他もないと言ったっても
我々は他を認識しているし
他を認識して煩悩を作ってるし
ですから人は勝手に来て
いえ 自我他もないんですよ
言ったっても私の煩悩は消えませんし
例えば般若心経だったら色は空であると重曹行何でしたっけ？それは空であると
そのまたないし 眼耳鼻舌身空ではまたない
色声味触 くだらないことを言うなと僕は言いたいんだけど
そんなこと言ったって私は持ってる問答
問題やら苦しみやら煩悩やら怒りやら消えるわけじゃないんだから
だから何の意味もないんです
そう言ったっても でも
哲学的によくよく考えると地水火風だから
こんなこと別にいなくたっていいんです
地水火風にしたっても
そんな四つ厳密に成り立たなくたっていいんですけど
だからといって我々にとってはそんな意味はないんですね
人の認識世界では煩悩は生まれるんだから
どこで煩悩生まれるかと
そこを発見して そこで煩悩を消さなくちゃいけないんですね
そういうことで 煩悩を消すためには
煩悩が生まれる場所を発見しなくちゃいけない
目で見て欲が生まれたならば
目を気をつけなくちゃいけない
目で見れるものは正しく見なくちゃいけない
例えば 何か人を見てすごく欲が生まれたんだと
それは自分が人という風に見たんだから
頭で推測したんだから
そこでいえ そうじゃなくて
目で見えたのは色だけですよと
ちゃんと認識するとその煩悩は消えてしまう
そういう風に煩悩はその場でその場で消えたらいい
そこで最終的に煩悩が生まれない働きが生まれてくる
それが解脱の道 それは否定して眼耳鼻舌身は空であると
また乃至色声香味触は空であるというのは
それはもう失礼な言葉で言えば邪教そのものなんですね
なぜならば 人のせっかく煩悩をなくすことができなくなっちゃうんだから
じゃあどこで煩悩生まれるかと聞きたくなるでしょ
そこで話を聞いたら煩悩はないんだと
そこで輪廻もない 解脱もないと
で もう般若 アヌッタラ・サンマクサんだから全部空であると
だからそこが哲学ではないんです
結局は いわゆる実践は抜けちゃいますからね
実践抜けちゃいますから
ただの概念の空回り 考えるならばどこまででも考えられる
この私は一生懸命説明したアビダンマも論理的に攻撃しようとすればできるんです
だから別に何も意味がないんです
ただ壊したいんだから壊し
壊しましたよ 壊して何が良かったのかでは壊してもいいし
まあそういうところで
まあ初期仏教の世界ではもう別に初期仏教は大丈夫で気にしてないんです
全く 気にしてないのは初期仏教は古いんだから
もう後から生まれたものは知らないです
だからまあ知らなかったんですね
知っていたならば簡単にもうそう
私の言ってることは言うだろうと思います
まあ一応注釈書の世界ではもう何となく微かに空論なんかはまあ一応
根拠はないということが言ってるんですね
ということですが テーラワーダの方が古いんですからね
まあ後の生まれた宗派っていうのは知らないんですね
じゃあまあそこでまあ十二終わったとして
まあ四時半ですね 四時まででしたっけ
四時半です  今日一回で席終わろうと思ったのに終わる終わるはずがない
まあこれからもうさっささっさと行きます
一応基本的にはまあこれぐらい意味があるということが分かればいいんですからね
次回からはもうちょっと子供
児玉 光のスピードじゃなくて児玉ぐらいのスピードでも行こうと思います
それで まあ望ぐらいに早さにして飛行機の早さにします
はい